-Ladies and gentlemen, it is
time for "Screen Grabs."
Here we go.
-♪ Makes me want a screen grab ♪
-These are some weird, funny
things that you guys found
on the Internet or took
a picture of in real life
and then sent it in to us.
This first screen grab
was sent in
by Nathan Waggoner in Albania.
He was shopping for some Legos
online and spotted this.
It's a 9,000-piece Lego set of
the Roman Colosseum, right?
And down here it says,
"Ages 18 months and up."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, really?
Yeah, babies love the Colosseum.
[ Laughter ]
What baby is putting together
a 9,000-piece Lego set?
This next one was sent in by
Brittany Stanley
in Alstead, New Hampshire.
She was browsing
Facebook Marketplace
and found this chair for sale.
Look at this.
It looks like
a pretty nice chair.
Let's see what it says up here.
"This chair is over 200 years
old and was used to prop people
up that had passed away
for photos. Very sturdy."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-You don't have to put
all the details of --
It's a chair!
-Yeah. 200-year-old chair.
Bunch of dead people.
-Yeah, used to --
-[ Laughing ]
What can you tell me about it?
-I seat dead people.
-Oh. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-It just -- It just comes.
You can't turn it off.
-It's like magic.
-Next one was a screen grab sent
in by Beth Pewnicky
in Manhattan, Illinois.
She spotted this headline
on her phone.
"Asteroid the size of
350 giraffes
to fly past Earth this week."
Very interesting unit of
measure.
[ Laughter ]
350 giraffes.
"How big's your house?"
"Oh, it's about four giraffes."
[ Laughter ]
"It's about 300 bunny rabbits
wide."
[ Laughter ]
"You okay, buddy?"
-Yeah.
-"We're good."
-Those gummies kicking in
right now?
What's happening?
This next screen grab
was sent in
by Stephanie Kelce
in Marin County, California.
-Yeah!
-Hey! Shout-out to Marin County.
She was trying to find a show
for her kids to watch,
and she found this right here.
This is called "Caillou."
Down here it says this episode
is "The search for the killer
of a popular postman
turns urgent
when additional bodies
are discovered."
[ Laughter ]
My kids love this show.
-Yeah, love it.
Love "Caillou."
-They sit around, they put
the 9,000-piece Legos.
[ Laughter ]
Put it in their --
-Then sit dead bodies in
the chair that Caillou found.
-They watch Caillou
figure it out.
Let Caillou figure it out.
No spoilers.
-No.
-This next screen grab was
sent in by Wade Sheckla
in Marina, California.
He was on a road trip with his
family in South Dakota,
and he was looking for some fun
local attractions.
Found this. Wade's Gold Mill.
30 people gave it 4.8 stars.
It's got good ratings.
Let's see when it's open.
Oh, it's closed
Monday through Saturday.
It's open from Sunday
12:00 to 12:01 a.m.
So, hey.
-Hey, it's Wade.
-You got a minute,
check this place out.
-It'll just take about a minute.
-This next screen grab
was sent in by
Justin Baker
in Shippensburg, Pennsylvania.
He spotted a used TV for sale
that someone posted online.
Look at this. It says,
"43-inch LG TV.
Has slight blue tint,
still works."
Can we see
the "slight blue tint"?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
"Slight"?
-"Slight."
-"You're watching
the Avatar Network."
Yeah, that is not slight.
-Next up, "The Smurfs."
-Completely blue.
-We're down to our last one.
This is from Christy Russell
in Chillicothe, Ohio.
She was watching
"Fiddler on the Roof."
She spotted a character in it
that she said looked like me.
And I don't know if I see this.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Does that look like me?
Let me try something.
♪♪
[ Wolf whistle ]
Thanks.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad. I kind of see it now.
That's all the time we have for
"Screen Grabs."
If you have a funny screen grab,
e-mail it to us
at screengrabs@tonightshow.com.
We might put it on the show.